the whole country was locked down last
year because the chronovirus that
chinese scientists made in a lab you
would think the country would be
safer because more people be inside but
the opposite happened
the united states has one of the most
dangerous
years in decades according to data
collected by the fbi
murders in this country increased by 25
percent
in fact that's probably a low ball we
don't have the complete data we won't
get until later this year
but as of now that means the united
states had more than 20
000 murders last year that's the highest
number in 26 years since 1995.
that rate was higher in the big cities
in chicago for example
murders increased by more than 50
percent in new york by 40 percent
one expert at the university of chicago
said last year was quote the largest
increase in violence we have seen since
1960
that's 61 years so why has this happened
in a year when people were locked in
doors why are more people murdering each
other
well the geniuses at vox are completely
baffled quote we don't yet
know what caused the violence they wrote
but actually we do know crime increased
because there were more criminals on the
streets fewer people but more criminals
now why were there more criminals on the
streets
because politicians released them during
the pandemic
according to a report for the department
of justice between march and june of
last year
208 thousand 500
inmates across the country received some
form of expedited release
some cities like new york released
almost half of
all its prison and jail inmates they
were quote
released to limit inmate risk and
exposure
in other words for their safety but what
about your safety
that was not taken into consideration
apparently they believed
it would be better for society better
for all of us
if criminals get out in the streets and
if those criminals committed more crimes
like many thousands more murders
that was worth it by june
which was when hundreds of thousands of
inmates had been released almost
38 inmates across the country had died
from the coronavirus so it wasn't really
about protecting
them from this deadly pandemic and of
course now that the coronavirus is
winding down you'd think politicians
would stop
releasing criminals onto the street but
they haven't stopped they're no longer
even
using coronavirus as an excuse last
month the state of california announced
that 76
000 inmates qualify for early release
from prison
about a quarter of those had life
sentences what does it take to get a
life sentence in california
a lot not someone you'd want to live
next to 76
000 keep in mind this is the same state
california where you can be charged with
a misdemeanor and spend 90 days in jail
if you violated your stay at home order
oh becoming clear lock down
normal decent law-abiding people release
the criminals
they're trying to wreck the country you
wouldn't do this if you weren't trying
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else